war-weary Americans are not ready to get
involved in another international
entanglement we asked Americans about
Russia's invasion of Ukraine and what
America should do about it six and ten
say America needs to stay out of it all
together even if Russia further invades
Ukraine Americans do not want the US
military to get involved they don't want
us to send military aid the only thing
Americans are willing to do is impose
economic sanctions and it's not because
they think that it will work it's more
of a symbolic gesture to tell Russia
that we don't approve of what they're
doing in the past Americans have been
very concerned about the power that
Russia's had because of the cold war in
this instance Russia is doing what
Americans were afraid it might do but
after Afghanistan in Iraq people don't
want to spread our military even thinner
than it is they don't want us to get
involved all the time I think these
results suggest to us that the Cold War
mentality is over Americans don't feel
like we need to get involved into every
international conflict that's going on
in order to protect our interests and
Ukraine is an example of this Americans
don't think we need to get involved